hey 42 here the placebo effect is one of
the least understood phenomenon known to
man in some cases is purely
psychological effect has the power to
completely heal people but how does it
work the word placebo comes from the
Latin I will please
there have been endless studies proving
that the placebo effect does work in
some clinical trials the placebo pills
actually outperformed the genuine
medication so how does it work well when
we get ill or hurt ourselves our body
puts up defenses against the real
problem for example if we catch the flu
our temperature rises but it's not the
flu virus that causes this our body
increases its internal temperature to
fight off the bacteria because it knows
bacteria can't survive in a hot
environment the placebo effect breaks
down these defenses because our own body
creates these symptoms it also has the
power to get rid of them so when we're
given a sugar pill and told it will cure
our illness an authority figure in this
case a doctor has given our brain
permission to stop its defenses so our
symptoms get better also when we're told
we've been given a pill that will cure
us our brain releases endorphins because
it's good news and because endorphins
are natural painkillers our symptoms
improve however the placebo effect
doesn't help fight the underlying virus
itself it only helps nullify the
experiences of the illness
despite this the a placebo effect has
been able to produce some amazing
physical results in clinical trials for
example it has made warts completely
disappear and even made bald men who
thought they were being given hairy
growth serum regrow their hair all with
the power of the
mind but the placebo effect has an evil
twin called the nocebo effect the nocebo
effect is when people are given a
harmless substance but succumb to
harmful effects when patients in double
blinded clinical trials are given sugar
pills and warned of the side-effects
they may experience if they're given the
real drug approximately 25 percent
experience severe side effects despite
the fact they're not actually taking the
medication another more disturbing study
showed in a group of patients about to
undergo life-threatening surgery those
who had convinced themselves they were
going to die usually did whereas
patients who had a more optimistic
outlook on their surgery usually
survived there exists a phenomena
associated with the nocebo effect called
voodoo death this is when a person is
cursed and told they will die and then
dies it sounds unbelievable
however there have been documented cases
where patients in hospital who are
believed to be terminally ill and
mistakenly told they have X amount of
time to live have then died within their
given timeframe
however after death an autopsy could
find no physiological explanation for
the early demise a lot of real
medication relies heavily on the placebo
effect to provide its full benefits this
is especially true with antidepressants
numerous studies have shown that
placebos produce the exact same results
as real antidepressants without any of
the side effects whilst this is good
news for sufferers their findings have
been heavily downplayed by major
pharmaceutical companies who would lose
out on billions of dollars if
antidepressants became less popular
here's another fun fact you can actually
[ __ ] bro yourself into an e BRE Asian
researchers found that people who were
told they had been drinking vodka
but we're really giving tonic water and
lime had impaired judgment and performed
much worse on basic IQ tests when it
comes to placebo pills the properties of
the drug itself can greatly affect its
performance researchers have found that
yellow placebo pills are the most
effective at treating depression whilst
red pills cause the patient to be more
alert and awake green pills ease anxiety
and white pills Sue's stomach pains they
also found that the more placebo pills
the patient takes the more effective
they are also pills that have a brand
name printed on them work better than
those that are blank studies have also
shown that when it comes to
over-the-counter medications such as
paracetamol a box of free dollar
medication is more effective than a
$0.40 box of medication despite both
products having the exact same active
ingredients this reveals that the
placebo effect is more powerful if the
perceived value of the medication is
higher but by far the biggest mystery
about the placebo effect is that it
works even when you know you're taking a
placebo in clinical trials where
patients are administered a placebo and
then they are eventually told that they
have been merely taking a sugar pill the
positive effects of the placebo remain
with absolutely no diminishment in
effectiveness in the future this means
doctors could be prescribing sugar pills
to patient when they know full well it's
a sugar pill the placebo effect is
powerful and it shows no signs of
stopping in fact is actually getting
stronger the placebo effect was first
discovered in the seventeen hundreds
weirdly it seemed the more tests that
medical professionals conduct the more
powerful a placebo effect has become
over the years it is wildly for this is
because of the growing belief in
medicine
as medical technology improves mortality
rates decreases and so our faith in the
medical system increases which
subsequently increases the power of the
placebo effect thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42